hello good morning mass speak to Doris
Lessing please hey Lisa this is adam
smith from the Nobel foundation's
website we have a tradition of recording
very short interviews on the telephone
with new laureates for our archives and
I was hoping that one might we might
speak for just a very few minutes okay
would it go hand in thank you very much
indeed congratulations of course thank
you I wonder have you had a chance to
see the citation from the swedish
academy no not really haven't seen you
know I was coming back at midday from
taking my son to the hospital I've never
seen anything written law that I did
talk to the the chap who runs of the
Nobel Committee so you spoken to Horace
Engdahl yes they describe you in their
citation as that episode of the female
experience who with skepticism fire and
visionary power has subjected a divided
civilization to scrutiny do you think
that goes some way towards capturing the
mission with which you write well I
don't really know what I had in mind
when they wrote it to see if some I mean
they were faced with a quite astonishing
number and range of writing the summers
all all that must have been quite for
double essential things not easy at all
you